we were talking about nine-to-five jobs
and I wanted to go to something that
I've heard other people talk about and
I've also experienced in the past and
that is you take the job and they know
you do other things outside of there and
they know that okay that's fine and
especially in LA most people aren't just
that job but then they start to get
weird with you
coworkers start to get weird right and
now we have social media and they can
kind of like see oh oh I see and it
starts to change on you and that's when
I've seen people get pushed out the door
or they start to make you sign things
that you're not making other employees
sign like you won't use your phone
during and you don't but you start to
see that the the parameters are
different for you for some reason I
don't know if you've experienced that
I've heard that from other people well
let me say this I didn't experience that
because I was way god by the time that
those kind of things started happening
but I know people that did experience
that and they would come to me the
person that had never experienced that
cuz who had been long gone and I would
tell them I say well that's telling you
it's time to go hmm without them having
to tell you that see when when when
stuff like that starts happening to
somebody that's an artist that's working
9:00 to 5:00 and don't get me wrong you
have to be able to sustain yourself and
to survive so if you need that work the
job
and you know people say well yeah should
I quit my job I say only if you can
sustain yourself without that job I say
otherwise you need that job because see
to do what we do as an artist this is
not today an age of like three four
hundred years ago when you know somebody
would be starving you know and a little
hamlet somewhere in England or somewhere
you know them days are over you have to
be able to sustain yourself if you out
here on the street and you don't have a
place to stay you're not an artist at
that point you out here fighting for
your life so if you have a job stay
there but you got to try to find a job
that's gonna allow you to pursue your
craft and know the real hard to find
like I mentioned the Nielson thing the
Nielson thing was cool
since because if you had something to do
you go do your audition or job or
whatever might not show up that day as
long as you got those passes out or
whatever you know they didn't have a
problem with that so you got to pretty
much find a job like that that's why a
lot of artists and actors and people are
waiters and servers and all kinds of
stuff like that because those are the
kind of jobs that people understand
enough and those are what I call
romantic jobs for actors and other the
few jobs that industry higher-ups have
no problem with an actor being or doing
because when I say romantic I mean in
the sense that all of the top people or
whatever at one point or another were
waiting tables since or valet you know
those are kind of jobs that top people
see a young aspiring actor doing like oh
okay
they remember their experience that that
it's no young what he's gonna really
grow and all that's nice but they'd less
but the industry people are less patient
with people working in corporate America
or behind a desk somewhere the industry
people are less patient with that
because they know the difficulty of
getting out of those jobs and see those
jobs you know they always starts
somebody off from what my friends have
told me they always start somebody off
oh sure you could take off you got an
audition go ahead after a few auditions
they started they start coming down on
the light what do you really you really
have to go or we really need you here to
do this so that then that affects the
actor with the agency what not then you
know they have to say well I can't make
it because I have a meeting that's when
the agents and people will say okay what
are you gonna do I can't be doing my job
here submitting you speaking up for you
to get in and say hey she's really good
well he's tops he's you need to see him
and you can't make it when I set the
audition now see so it starts working
like that starts working like that so it
becomes a point where if an actor
or a singer or whatever you are in the
industry if you're really really serious
about doing this in this business you
got eventually say okay I gotta leave
that yeah and if it means like if you
making 40 50 60 thousand or whatever a
hundred thousand or whatever on a
corporate job and you really really
aspire to be in this business you might
have to leave that job and go get you a
job making $12 an hour to be able to do
that and that takes a hell of a lot to
do because I mean if you married or have
children or something it becomes
difficult because once you have children
or something like that and I and it
doesn't matter to me whether you in the
arts or whatever to me if you have
children they come first the business is
all that comes after that no matter how
much I love acting or whatever if I got
a bunch of kids or I got a child that
child comes first and that's the way it
should be when anybody so it's it's a
real tough thing to do it's a tough nut
to crack and you have to just finally
just be real with yourself like I was
saying earlier you can't be with
somebody that's not gonna let you be you
this is this is the thing that's hard
about this job we do and that we're not
even talking about the actual rejection
which is 99.9% of it you know getting
rejected and how people you know I've
had friends they were much more talented
than me they had to leave the business
because they couldn't handle the
rejection and I'm like wow and when I
first got it it I I had a little trouble
at first and then I had a I had somebody
in the business my mentor who passed
away years ago he told me he says you
better get over that he said because you
don't get rejected hell of a lot more
than you're gonna get accepted he says
so now I'm like wow yeah and I've
learned this side is I mean you know we
all I'm not gonna sit here and say oh
well I've mastered that I don't
I can handle rejection well it gets you
times cuz he human I mean
maybe real you know human being and
sometimes it hit you
sometimes I hit you not only just
affected dam that job was gonna pay me a
lot of money
other times I hit you Wow I thought I
was really good and that's that's the
part I want to play and not even
considering any money it's just affected
your your artistic thing was like man I
could really get into that role that's a
challenging role that would be really
good for me to do that and you don't get
it so it hits you in a lot of ways so so
you just got it eventually and there's a
theme I keep going back to got to be
true to yourself you got to be true to
yourself you got to be true to yourself
not only as far as a job you got to be
true to yourself as far as can I handle
what I'm doing can I handle this can I
handle the fact that I'm gonna not have
a lot of money at certain points or I'm
not gonna get a job I'm gonna be
depressed about [ __ ] can I handle this
and you have to just finally say okay
yes I can no I can't
and all these friends I had to left the
business and whatnot when I see them or
I go home you know for the holidays or
or Facebook or they some weeks it's Dan
touch we'll talk I don't I don't hold
anything against them as fries them not
being an actor you're not an actor
anymore so I can't relate to you oh
these are friends these are people what
I love and care for and I tell people I
say hey and what I always do is most of
my friends that have to leave the
business out of here most of them go
home and don't have any money and cable
to get home I provide everybody a way to
get home
I sent many friends home not on the
ground because I wouldn't do that to him
you coming from LA to Chicago or Detroit
or New York that's a hell of a long ride
doesn't make you wanna Keys up
so I fly them home I mean I don't send
people home one-way tickets and I have
people say you always send somebody on
them I said I'd do that because if they
broker whatever and they can't get out
of here and they need to go I offer my
had a friend who left she drove she
drove out I said are you gonna make any
that conscious I'm gonna make it and she
said well I'm gonna need about $200 I
said okay I gave it to
dollars and other people says you gave
her $200 how's it yeah she got to go
home she like Dorothy she's got to go
home
she clicking in heels and get the hell
out of it she's got to go go
how about help me get out of here
because that's what you have to do and
people thank me and that's harm and I
said I would hope you would do it for me
if that were the case I sent people home
I mean I'm sending two or three people
home a year
you